when the coronavirus was rapidly
spreading across the u.s
in april and may last year paramedics in
new york city responded
to more than 7 thousand calls a day
many in the city and other areas
couldn't get over the trauma
last year john mondello died by suicide
now his mother eileen is joining others
to push for more mental health services
for frontline workers mola lenghi spoke
with her in her first on camera
interview
about her son's struggle
the calls kept coming and emts like
deputy chief aj briones kept answering
on the front lines of the coveted
pandemic what those emts saw
is tough to shake they never had time to
think once it started slowing down
that's what you actually had to worry
worry he says about the toll on
paramedics mental health
ptsd is a rabbit hole you get angry for
no reason
you lose who you are part of it feels
like you're being a burden to someone
else
part of it is
reliving those moments mary full of
grace
eileen mandela was an icu coveted nurse
when she received a call that her 23
year old son
john an emt had taken his own life
john watch over me shine your light on
me
i love you john my son had dreams
of a future
and that was taken by this pandemic john
mandela was fresh out of the emt academy
when the pandemic hit he was sent to the
busiest 911 volume in the city
his mother says stress and anxiety
consumed him
i think that realization of i'm here to
save lives but i can't save you
and i didn't realize how that affected
me
until very recently we sat down with
john's partner delilah woods
shakira tate and alexander puska to talk
about the mental health of emts
i'm sort of taboo to bring that up i
guess right exactly
because you know the job wants you to be
present present exactly there's
definitely days where
i didn't sleep there was definitely days
where
i had dreams of people hanging
themselves
um i guess at one point
i was having suicidal thoughts myself
i think you definitely do need a better
support
system that's in place for us first
responders not only just as
or an ems does the fdny have enough
mental health resources in place
i believe they have enough now but to
say that it's enough for
forever no it's an ongoing process
fdny lieutenant crystal hayes is an ems
peer support coordinator would it
surprise you to hear that some emts
say that more resources are needed no
not at all
sometimes people need more than what we
can provide
and then we can either outsource them to
somebody that can help them better than
what the department
can in yonkers new york deputy chief
ryona says the strongest thing someone
can do
is ask for help it's not a been there
done that
attitude it's i've been there i know how
to help you
i want there to be more counseling made
available
and my biggest hope is that no mother
should ever feel the way that i do
what would you say to mothers who
have a son or a daughter who may be
struggling right now i would say
don't take any change in personality
for granted if you see your son or
daughter becoming anxious
act on it immediately if you're wrong
and you're exaggerating that's okay
because once
something like this happens there's no
turning back
now if you need immediate help call the
24 7 national suicide prevention
lifeline at 1-800-2732
it is free it is confidential fdny
also offers a similar hotline to their
emts and has a counseling services unit
which provides a range of therapy
options
for groups as well as individuals giving
them a chance to talk to current and
retired members
who can help guys talking is the first
and most important step and it's often
the hardest one too
yeah and i think i mean listen their job
is hard enough in normal times
covid was just overwhelmed just
overwhelming i can't imagine
the resources need to be available for
them and they have to feel that they can
access them
works both ways it works and that is the
key they've got to feel comfortable
in accessing those resources great story
thanks
mola thank you very much